the modern warfare 2 beta may have a
release window and it seems like your
starfield character won't be talking
much
call of duty modern warfare 2 is getting
a beta and according to an amazon
product page it could be coming in
august the page for modern warfare 2 on
playstation 5 says players who pre-order
will receive their beta code in august
the xbox series x and s page gets a
little more specific and says that those
who pre-order by august 15th will unlock
early access to the open beta now this
could suggest that the open beta will
start before then because once the early
access period ends anyone can jump in
however it's important to keep in mind
that activision has yet to announce any
dates but enough of activision let's
talk about its other half blizzard last
week diablo 4 game director joe shelley
revealed why the game doesn't have any
brand new classes according to shelley
the decision came down to player
expectations and making sure that the
aspects fans remember from previous
diablo games are present in diablo 4
albeit in a new modern form diablo
community lead adam fletcher recently
confirmed the plan is to eventually sell
paid expansions for d4 meaning it's
certainly possible that new classes
could be added to the game post-launch
but diablo 4 isn't coming until 2023 you
know what else isn't coming until then
starfield over on twitter bethesda
confirmed that you'll be a silent
protagonist in the new game this is
notable because fallout 4 the last
single player rpg from bethesda broke
new ground by having you play a voiced
character fallout 76 went back to the
silent trend though that was a large
multiplayer rpg the presentation at the
xbox and bethesda showcase made a point
to show how flexible the character
creator is in star field and like in
other bethesda rpgs you'll have loads of
dialogue options informed by your
characteristics and other choices but
you won't hear your created character
speak in their dialogue aloud this time
fan reactions seem split some have
expressed disappointment in the silent
protagonist trope saying it breaks
immersion others say they prefer silence
as opposed to hearing a performance of a
line you just read personally i prefer
when my characters speak but let me know
what you prefer in the comments below
i'll see you again tomorrow
you